SPEAKER: "The Whirligig" is
presented by the New Group,
in associated with Lisa Matlin.
And everyone, please
help me welcome
cast and creatives
from "The Whirligig".
[APPLAUSE]
DOLLY WELLS: [INAUDIBLE]
clap for myself.
NORBERT LEO BUTZ: You can clap
for yourself, it's all right.
SPEAKER: And so, I guess we
should go down the line here.
We have Norbert Leo
Butz, of course.
And Dolly Wells, Zosia Mamet.
Hamish already raised his hand,
and then artistic director
Scott Elliott.
I want to start with the
concept of the show, Hamish.
Where did this even come from?
[STAMMERING]
[LAUGHTER]
HAMISH LINKLATER: Yes, yes.
I don't know.
SPEAKER: Take your time.
HAMISH LINKLATER: I
started writing some scenes
with some people in it, and had
a really good idea for a play.
And then it fell apart.
And I put those scenes away.
SPEAKER: How long ago was that?
HAMISH LINKLATER: That
was about four years ago.
And they moldered and festered.
And then I pulled them
out of the drawer.
And I was shooting a movie
in Richmond, Virginia.
I had a lot of time on my hands.
I had too small a part.
Then suddenly, this play filled
up the rest of like 10 days
by the river.
And it came out.
Yeah, that's how I
wrote the play, I think.
SPEAKER: So that's how, but why?
HAMISH LINKLATER: Why
did I write the play?
Because I had too much time on
my hands in Richmond, Virginia.
No, I think the play is
about loss, to a degree.
And I think I probably
had experienced some loss.
And it was giving me a rash.
And I needed to scratch it.
And so I scratched
it with my pen.
Out of that ooze came the play.
NORBERT LEO BUTZ: Oh, lord.
HAMISH LINKLATER: Yeah,
sometimes the playwright
should shut up.
SCOTT ELLIOTT: He
writes very well.
SPEAKER: Oh yeah.
The show, I saw it Friday
night, which I think
was your second night open.
Incredible.
I just want you to keep talking.
You're quite interesting
to listen to.
So oftentimes, it takes of
course years of writing.
And you said it
was four years ago
when you were down shooting
in the wonderful hills
of Virginia.
And writing development, and we
get the show through workshops,
and then through
off-Broadway, and then
to Broadway, and
the whole process.
I know you're not
on Broadway, but--
SCOTT ELLIOTT: Yet.
SPEAKER: Yet.
What was the process--
this is still for creatives
here, Scott and Hamish.
How did you finish
up the script?
What was the timeline?
How did, Scott, you get
involved, and be like,
yes, that's what we want?
SCOTT ELLIOTT: Yeah, well,
I read a lot of plays
every year, having to
pick a few to produce.
And Hamish's agent
sent us the play.
And I read it.
And I had an experience
while I was reading it.
It was one of those ones
where I found myself laughing,
and then I couldn't
stop crying at the end.
And so just that
reaction made me say,
OK, I have to figure
out a way to do this.
It's a very complicated
play, for those of you
who might come check it
out, just in the logistics
of the whole thing.
And it took me a minute to
figure out how to do it.
And then I just
decided to do it.
It was not a hard one--
it didn't go through
a million workshops.
We did, I think,
one little workshop.
And only Zosia was
in that workshop.
And Zosia, I think, fell
in love with the play
just the same time I did.
We had a love affair
together that weekend.
And we decided we were going to
do it together over a year ago.
It just was you know
one of those plays.
I love stories that are
small and relatable,
but are about big things.
And that's what this play is.
SPEAKER: You said you
wanted to figure out
how you were going to do it.
Did you mean physically in
terms of the stage itself?
Because whirligig-- I mean,
what is the definition
of a whirligig here?
HAMISH LINKLATER:
I've forgotten.
SPEAKER: Well, I've got
it right in front of me.
I was setting you up.
It is one, noun, a
toy that spins around,
for example a top or pinwheel.
Two, a thing regarded as
hectic or constantly changing,
such as a whirligig of time.
So the characters
in this play all
seem to circulate
around each other.
They've got past lives, and then
their present lives have all
brought them back, which
is-- the term I coined,
full circle,
everything comes back.
But then the stage
itself is also--
it's a turntable.
It's a whirligig.
SCOTT ELLIOTT: Right.
SPEAKER: So is there--
When you said how you
were going to do it,
did you mean in terms of--
SCOTT ELLIOTT: Well, it
doesn't just have a turntable.
That was just something
that I envisioned.
That wasn't in the script.
But it also has people climbing
trees and things like that,
which seems almost impossible.
And just trying to figure out
a way to do that, artistically,
poetically, and within a budget,
it became very challenging.
But then my set designer
and I, Derek McLane,
came up with some ways to
do the little tricks in it.
The play is-- it
sounds depressing
but it's very, very
fanciful and charming.
I wanted to just get that feel.
And the turntable helped
me create some surprises
in the visual life of the story.
SPEAKER: It's
interesting, because when
the audience loads in,
one of the actresses
is already on stage.
And she's been sitting
there spinning for how long?
SCOTT ELLIOTT: That's
why she's not here today.
She's nauseous.
No.
No, she's a delightful young
actress, Grace Van Patten.
You will hear a lot about
her very soon, I imagine.
No, I just wanted--
because it's about a girl
who is losing her life.
And really, as I watched
the play five times
this week, it seems
that the play--
a young woman is
losing her life,
and that's what sends everybody
into this whirligig of life.
And they emerge grown, I think.
And that's the sort
of moral of the story
SPEAKER: So Norbert
and Dolly, how
did you two get attached to it?
DOLLY WELLS: It was
cast without me.
And then I very luckily came
in quite close to the opening,
because the person
that had the part
was then not able to do it.
And I read the play, and felt
incredibly excited, but was not
going to let myself get too
excited, because I thought,
I'm at the end of
a very long list.
That's what happened.
SCOTT ELLIOTT: And we had
had a drink once before.
DOLLY WELLS: Yeah, definitely.
HAMISH LINKLATER: And you wanted
to continue the relationship,
right?
DOLLY WELLS: And I think
that's why you wrote the play.
Yeah.
Almost as much as you did.
Anyway, what about you, Norbert?
NORBERT LEO BUTZ: I just
met Hamish once or twice.
And just to know Hamish is
just to fall in love with him.
And I've been a huge fan
of his work as an actor.
He is one of my favorite
working actors in New York City.
I've seen him several
times on stage.
He's quite brilliant.
And so when he sent me an email
with a play attached to it,
I was a little bit--
the actor slash
playwright, there
was a little bit of an eye roll.
Maybe a slight eye
roll, like oh god,
here's another
dilettante writer,
and quickly realized
this is a real writer--
a real writer.
I couldn't believe-- and I did
so with some major jealousy.
How could someone be
such a good performer
and write so beautifully?
I fell in love with the
play on first reading.
And Hamish said he had just
had me in mind for the role.
And I just jumped on.
I think there's a tradition
of actor playwrights.
And I think Hamish really does,
he joins the Tracy Letts, Bruce
Norris school of contemporary
actors who write, not because--
I don't know, I could
be wrong-- because they
need to prove that they can do
something else besides acting.
Like I said, he's a real writer.
But the joy of
doing a play by is
someone who is an actor as
well, so much of the word
is already on the page.
It's very actor-friendly.
It's a play for actors.
It's all about the characters.
It's all about the minds and
hearts of these sort of quiet,
maybe some would say
insignificant lives.
But I love stories that are
about quiet, insignificant
lives.
The play reminded me of--
I like short stories.
And I've been reading a lot
of Chekhov short stories.
And I have for a
long, long time.
There's something Chekhovian
about these characters.
In fact, there's a
wonderful passage
that sort of hearkens to "The
Cherry Orchard," that one
character gets to say, "I love
the short stories of Alice
Munro and people like that who
just sort of take Polaroids
of people's lives, that
you would pass by and not
think twice about
what was going on."
And I just love that.
We get to be voyeurs into
these simple people who are
dealing with unspeakable loss.
SPEAKER: That was
a very good answer
for a very simple question.
NORBERT LEO BUTZ:
Oh, give me a minute.
[LAUGHING]
SPEAKER: So then, for all
three of the cast members
here, what was your first
reaction when you actually
did read the script
for the first time?
Because it touches on so many
different levels of-- there's
a lot of comedic relief
written into it, but I wonder,
too, Norbert, your character
specifically, how much of that
is you bringing the
comedy to it versus what's
written on the page.
But that's a second question.
Again, my first question is
what was your first impression?
NORBERT LEO BUTZ:
I was really moved.
I found it incredibly relatable.
I'll just be very candid and
say that the character is
a father of a young girl
between the ages of 17 and 23,
we see her.
I have three daughters myself.
My oldest daughter is 20.
I have a 17-year-old.
I could relate.
I thought it was extremely
authentic, the dialogue,
very funny.
I don't know how this
approaching-middle-aged man
gets the vernacular of
teenage girlhood so spot-on.
He has two daughters himself.
I just recognized immediately,
Hamish has two daughters
as well.
This guy has just an
open, bleeding heart
full of love for his child.
And that was relatable.
He's an actor and an acting
teacher, the character is.
There were some
wonderfully funny scenes
where I get to kind of
send up, a little bit,
the cliche of the
acting teacher,
of the sort of narcissist
acting teacher.
The jokes were really funny.
Hamish also has--
I'm going to keep on
raving about Hamish,
but I first loved
him on "The New
Adventures of Old Christine."
You remember him on that show?
He's so funny.
And But there's proper jokes
in the show, and not jokes
that have punch lines,
but that come out
of the situations
and the characters.
And I really responded to that.
DOLLY WELLS: I found
it incredibly sad.
I remember reading
it with my husband,
and I couldn't-- there were
scenes neither of us could get
to the end of without crying.
I thought I thought it was very,
very beautiful, very sad, very
funny.
I agree with what
Norbert said, that there
were jokes that
were coming out-- it
all comes out of
such a real place.
And these people are all--
god, imagine if I
started crying now,
how embarrassing that would be.
I'm not going to.
[LAUGHING]
SPEAKER: Look at the picture
on the wall over here.
DOLLY WELLS: All the characters
are so brave and sympathetic
and full of--
I mean, it's the most
awful situation that--
I am also a mother
with two children
and one teenage daughter.
The setting and the
situation is so awful,
but there's such beautiful,
specific moments of joy
and hope and that--
I hadn't read a play like that.
And also, without
giving things away,
the time structure I
was just very excited
about when I first read it.
So I felt-- and this
is the first play
I've done since I've
come to New York,
and I haven't done
very many before,
so it felt like,
wow, to be able to do
this brand-new, exciting,
delicate thing felt just really
exciting.
And the part of
Christina is so--
well, she's a very unhappy--
I don't want to give too
much away, because you're all
going to see it.
You're all going to bring
lots of people to see it.
But she doesn't have such a
bleeding heart as her husband
and her ex-husband.
She finds it much
harder to communicate,
to work out what she's feeling.
She's a bit more withdrawn
and cold and confused.
So there's a huge amount
of regret for her,
and there's a huge
amount of unspoken--
I'm garrulous, and
I haven't really
played a character
like that before.
And I found that very
exciting, and a challenge.
And the cast, I mean the whole
situation seemed like a dream.
So I didn't want
to get too excited.
But when I read it,
I was gobsmacked.
I couldn't stop thinking
about all of them.
ZOISA MAMET: Such a good word.
[INAUDIBLE]
He just told me you're fired.
DOLLY WELLS: I thought I'd be
told at the end of previews,
but I didn't know it would be
in front of everyone, but OK.
It's fine.
ZOISA MAMET: I echo
everything that they said.
And I am a big believer that
true and great comedy arises
out of necessity.
We laugh in the darkest
moments, because we have to.
Otherwise we implode and die.
It's why people
laugh at funerals,
or when something
terrible happens,
you somehow get the giggles.
And it feels so
inappropriate, but I
think it's sort of your
body's reaction to attempting
to process something that's
impossible to process
in real time.
And when I read
Hamish's play, it's
so heartbreaking in the most
beautiful and, like Dolly said,
delicate way.
But it's also so fucking
funny, because it has to be.
Because if it wasn't,
these people would die.
They'd kill themselves,
because there is no reason
to go on living otherwise.
And I think these
very hard humans
who are faced with this
incredible tragedy and the need
to process their own guilt
and blame surrounding it--
Hamish has just does this
incredible and beautiful job
of writing the way that
they navigate this story,
and the way that
they navigate trying
to climb over their grief
and continue living.
SPEAKER: Is this all
new for you, Hamish?
HAMISH LINKLATER:
It's very accurate.
I can't imagine the play you
guys all must be imagining.
[LAUGHING]
SPEAKER: Sorry to interrupt.
Go ahead.
ZOISA MAMET: We're really just
setting it up for all of us
to fail here really--
SPEAKER: Because I'm
here looking at Scott
with this weird
look on his face.
I was like, is
this the first time
he's heard any of you
guys talk about him?
DOLLY WELLS: No.
ZOISA MAMET: Those are
just the faces he makes.
NORBERT LEO BUTZ:
And I just wanted
to say one other thing too.
Something about the play
that struck me right away
is its total lack of cynicism.
I don't know about
all of you, but it was
a hard year in a lot of ways.
For a lot of us it felt like
the bottom really fell out.
We were culturally, socially,
in a whirligig, I think,
in a lot of ways.
And so this idea that
a group of people
come together to hold
each other up, I suppose--
it's a play about community,
really at the end of the day.
It's about eight characters
who get through something
through and with each other.
We all need each
other up on the stage.
And we need each other
without cynicism.
That hit me real hard
when I read the play.
Maybe it was at the time
that I got the play.
But that's what I most
love about "The Whirligig."
SPEAKER: So all of
the actors, Scott,
have very long and illustrious--
and even the writer--
acting careers in front of
the camera for TV and movies.
Is there anything
that-- as a director,
do you have to adjust what you
do based on what they bring,
because they have a
different background, versus
a traditional theater-only
type of actor?
Or does that even exist?
Or you just say, "Have at it!
Here's the word."
HAMISH LINKLATER: Every
one is its own animal.
When you get a group of people
together, and you try to--
I personally try to make
it seem like everybody's
in the same world.
And so sometimes you have
to nudge somebody in one way
or in another way
to sort of make sure
that everybody feels like
they live in the same world.
Because that's, in
my opinion, when
you watch a show or
a movie or something
like that, if it's off balance,
it doesn't seem authentic.
It seems a little fraudulent.
And so I really work hard
thinking about a world.
And every world is different.
Sometimes you do a
very different tone.
It's really just about the
sort of tone that you're after.
And as far as people being--
I mean talent is talent
and technique is technique,
I guess.
And so some people who
are incredibly talented
have to figure out
things in their technique
to help them out.
And so you just try to help
people figure out the balance.
And sometimes you hit them.
But it's always with love.
That's always my goal.
Whether a show works or not
for me, is when I watch it,
I feel like, ah,
it feels like I'm
watching a world where everybody
inhabiting it is the same one.
SPEAKER: And the person
I went to see it with
commented afterwards
she said to me,
"I felt like I just
watched a movie."
And I was thinking
about that comment.
I was thinking about the
whole thing over the weekend,
because I saw it
on Friday night.
And it sat with me for
a couple of reasons.
Being a parent myself,
it hit me on that level.
But then just in terms of
just being damn good theater,
it was on that level.
And then my friend's
comment about being a movie,
it just occurred
to me why we felt
that based on what you
said, is that everything was
so perfectly complementary
of each other,
including the actors were
all on the same level,
the set was not intrusive,
but complemented
everybody's performance.
So there's actually
no question here.
I just wanted to add on--
SCOTT ELLIOTT:
But the story sort
of unfolds in a
cinematic way, in that--
not a lot of playwrights
write three-line scenes.
And I think that that was
a challenge, in a way,
to sort of do.
But I knew that they were
essential to capture the sort
of absurdity of the situation.
And there's no blackouts.
I decided to not have
any blackouts in it,
and try to figure it out.
It took-- I think
the actors wanted
to kill me-- it
took a while, but I
think now it all worked out.
SPEAKER: Oh, no,
it was wonderful.
Along those lines,
with no blackouts--
hello, audience, I will
tell you was going on.
The stage turns, so
you're looking at a scene,
and then that
scene moves upstage
while another scene
comes downstage,
or someone sitting
in a tree, like Zoisa
sits in a tree for what
seems like an hour.
ZOISA MAMET: Forever.
SPEAKER: Yeah, 20 minutes?
And the tree limb
itself lifts up,
so you're a good 30, 40 feet
off the stage at some point.
ZOISA MAMET: 25.
SPEAKER: Like 60, 70 feet.
SCOTT ELLIOTT: 25, but she's
stoned, so add another 20.
SPEAKER: Fake stoned, remember?
Fake stoned, like fake news.
What do you guys do when
you're waiting to come back on?
Is there anything you have
to do to just not fall off
that branch?
ZOISA MAMET: In the tree?
SPEAKER: Yeah.
ZOISA MAMET: What do we do?
We stare at the audience.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, Johnny and I
just people watch.
Because we can't say anything,
because we don't want to pull
focus from the scenes
below us, but we just
watch people in the audience.
SPEAKER: Have you ever
noticed anything unusual?
You're like, that
guy's picking his nose.
ZOISA MAMET: No one's done
anything super embarrassing
yet, but there's still time.
DOLLY WELLS: She
tells us there's
people in the
audience that aren't
there just to terrify us.
ZOISA MAMET: Oh, yeah.
The other night it
was Stephen Spielberg.
Last night it was Judith Light.
NORBERT LEO BUTZ:
Terrifying Judith Light.
ZOISA MAMET: I actually
thought I saw her last night.
SCOTT ELLIOTT: They're supposed
to be looking in somebody's
window the whole time.
Now I know.
So we found out what
really is going on.
SPEAKER: Is your
character motivation
to find Judith Light?
Yes.
I get that.
SCOTT ELLIOTT: Where in
the world is Judith Light?
SPEAKER: That would be a funny--
in terms of the
audience itself, though.
You've only been open
for a couple of days now,
but have you received any
unusual audience feedback,
or things that you may or may
not have expected from this?
Any of you?
DOLLY WELLS: I wasn't
ready for him the volume
of the talking in the audience.
Like in the matinee, I just
had someone go "Oh, my god."
But they were sitting,
there were so close.
And then you hear, "Is
that the one from--"
They're trying to
work out who you are.
Or the chatting, I
wasn't so prepared for.
Just hearing--
SPEAKER: You mean just
poor etiquette of--
DOLLY WELLS: Yeah, just
talking to each other.
ZOISA MAMET: That's just
because we're terrible Americans
with no manners.
And you're not used to it.
DOLLY WELLS: I
remember the first time
I came to the
theater in America,
and I was so surprised, and
that hasn't happened yet,
which is devastating--
is that someone came on stage,
and everyone went, "Woo!"
Which does not happen in London.
And it was Orlando Bloom
in "Romeo and Juliet."
And he didn't have his shirt on,
and people were just screaming,
so I'm--
NORBERT LEO BUTZ:
I was one of them.
DOLLY WELLS: I'm devastated
that I haven't even got--
NORBERT LEO BUTZ: It was
Orlando Bloom, come on.
DOLLY WELLS: That's true, OK.
NORBERT LEO BUTZ:
Without his shirt on.
ZOISA MAMET: Come out without
your shirt on, they might--
DOLLY WELLS: They might cry.
[LAUGHING]
Maybe I'll try
that one tomorrow.
SCOTT ELLIOTT: I'm
fascinated sometimes,
because when we do
shows-- and I always
know they're working
in a weird way
when sometimes the
audience talks at it.
Or I always love in the
show, when about that key--
you know what I mean?
You won't understand
this, but they
say, oh, he's locked the door.
They sort of say the line with,
him as if they're so into it
that they recite it with him.
It's so interesting.
DOLLY WELLS: And there's
another scene I won't give away
between Norbert and another--
SCOTT ELLIOTT: They won't
really remember the scenes
even if you give it away.
DOLLY WELLS: And you
hear the audience go--
[SURPRISED GASP]
Which I love, every time.
SCOTT ELLIOTT: Yeah,
there's a lot of gasping.
And it's interesting.
DOLLY WELLS: They gasp.
SCOTT ELLIOTT: I think that
means people are with it,
and I find that exciting,
because that's part of--
NORBERT LEO BUTZ: Either
that or my overacting
offended them so much.
They were like--
[SURPRISED GASP]
I can't believe
he did that again!
SCOTT ELLIOTT: You
could feel that people
are engrossed when they react.
It's like they have
a visceral reaction.
They can't control themselves.
They have to say something.
It's interesting, I think.
And part of the--
I always say the audience
is the next character.
It's like a character
in a play, an audience.
You never you're going
to get any night.
SPEAKER: Just talking,
Norbert, to your over-acting.
NORBERT LEO BUTZ:
Oh, [INAUDIBLE], it
gets its own subject heading?
SPEAKER: On my tablet, I
have overacting right here.
No, obviously It's working well.
You've won a couple
Tony awards and such.
DOLLY WELLS: Your overacting--
[LAUGHTER]
NORBERT LEO BUTZ: Wow.
DOLLY WELLS: You so
walked into that.
You asked for it.
SPEAKER: This is
a question for you
and, I guess, Hamish
and Scott, too.
Your character is
a very eccentric.
That was my earlier question
that we didn't answer--
how much of that did you bring
to the page, and how much of it
was written in the
script already?
NORBERT LEO BUTZ: Well,
that's the strange thing
about what we do.
There's a silent amalgamation,
something that happens.
That's what you look for.
I don't know how to answer that
other than to say of course
it's all coming from the page.
It has to start with the words.
I haven't improved anything.
I've added nothing.
The play is so well-written.
So I haven't added
anything to it.
The language is there.
So anything that I'm
doing, my imagination
has been sparked from what's
right there on the page.
It's my job to sort of
find within me, Norbert,
my sensibility of
Michael, this man.
You I really try not
to over-think it.
You learn it
really, really well.
You learn it perfectly,
as best you can.
Hamish is a real
stickler about--
"There's actually not
an and in that sentence,
there's actually--"
And he's dead right.
Every time, he's dead right.
There's a reason that
the and is not there.
The line is funnier without it.
Or it's odder without it.
You try to do exactly
what's on the page,
and then let go and try to fly.
HAMISH LINKLATER: I will say
that I so enjoy acting myself.
And I love being an actor.
And I love other actors so much.
And so if I'm going to force
someone to go up on a stage
and say something
that I've written,
I hope it will give
them joy to do it,
and joy to the
audience to receive it.
I do tend to write
bigger characters who
have large emotional lives.
And when I go on stage, I
want to make people laugh,
and I want to make people cry.
So I wouldn't want to just--
what does that, play it forward,
pay it forward, whatever?
ZOISA MAMET: Pay
it forward, yeah.
HAMISH LINKLATER:
Pay for forward.
Yeah, I did know
what I was saying.
Damn it.
Certainly while putting
together this cast,
the consideration
was, we want people
who are going to eat
up the stage, that
are going to go for it.
Because then,
everyone in the house
is going to be having a
good time at the same time.
Norbert is doing it.
And so it's really great.
And Zosia as well.
And Dolly, really, too.
SPEAKER: Except
you just fired her.
[LAUGHTER]
So from your perspective, Scott.
Is there anything that--
are you just there to be like,
yep, check all the boxes.
Or, you're a director.
How much do you direct
these wonderful people?
SCOTT ELLIOTT: I don't know.
I don't know how
other people do it.
I guess I always speak my mind.
I'm honest.
I try to offer help and insight,
and try not to hover too much,
let people have a little leeway.
But I also try to be
really honest, because I
want everybody to excel.
I want everybody in the theater
to feel every performance.
Also, I'm dedicated to the
play and Hamish, and so--
HAMISH LINKLATER: Scott
does an unbelievable job
of changing my diapers,
and soothing me.
It's unbelievable.
During the show, I'm just
like a wiggly, wiggly baby.
But the way that he has
mentored me and cared
for me during this
process, has just
been unspeakably invaluable.
I'm so grateful to him.
SPEAKER: So audience, if
you guys have any questions,
we have two mics in the aisles.
Please start to line up.
You can ask anybody anything.
I want to go back, though,
to the set real fast.
I think it's kind of interesting
that, for these shows
that have such a highly evolved
technical aspect, not that this
is [INAUDIBLE]
technical, but you're
very reliant on a turntable.
Do you have a contingency plan?
Like, what if that turntable
messes up, screws up?
Has it screwed up?
HAMISH LINKLATER: Do we?
Do we, Scott?
ZOISA MAMET: Don't
ask that question.
SPEAKER: Is there--
HAMISH LINKLATER:
[INAUDIBLE] wood in here?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SCOTT ELLIOTT: We have
very experienced people
working on all of the
aspects of the production.
And yeah, it does rely on
it, but if, god forbid,
something happened, they
would still do the play.
The stage is actually--
it's interesting,
the stage is raked.
So you can see behind--
you can see what's going on.
So I don't think, if
they just did the play,
it would just be wonderful.
You just wouldn't see my
staging, which is really
just enhancing the play.
SPEAKER: Right.
Raked means angled.
SCOTT ELLIOTT: The
play is amazing,
so the staging just gives
it a little something.
But when we did a
workshop of the play,
and we were all just
sitting around the table
and reading the play,
it was obvious to us
that just the actual
play is so beautiful.
So I guess if something
happens, thanks a lot.
SPEAKER: Blame me.
SCOTT ELLIOTT: I'm
going to call you.
SPEAKER: Just blame me, text me.
SCOTT ELLIOTT: I am going
to come and wake you up,
and your child.
SPEAKER: That's just mean.
They're young, let them sleep.
Zosia, everybody on
the stage, actually,
and we'll get all of you.
Zosia, you've got a
long family history
of being in performing
arts and whatnot.
Your father-- yes,
that shouldn't
be a surprise, your father David
Mamet founded Atlantic Theater
Company here, attached
to this building.
So you've never
been inside Google,
but you've been in the building,
you said, plenty of times.
Does your relationship
with him, do you think,
this is sort of on a
more general note--
has your relationship
with your father
being successful
as he is influenced
the choices that you've made
as your own independent career?
ZOISA MAMET: No.
SPEAKER: Fair.
Fair.
All right, next question.
Norbert!
Seven of 11 children.
NORBERT LEO BUTZ: Yep.
SPEAKER: Are any of them
as wonderful over-actors
as you are?
NORBERT LEO BUTZ: [INAUDIBLE].
SPEAKER: Where did
you get your start?
Is it a family thing?
NORBERT LEO BUTZ: Yes,
I'm the seventh of 11.
I think I got my
start just trying
to be heard over the
din of that household,
gave me the instrument
that you hear before you.
I grew up in a suburb
of St. Louis, Missouri.
And then after age seven,
way out in the country
in a very, very,
very small town.
No theater at all to speak of.
My parents were
devout Christians,
so limited music, limited film.
And that was a great way
to be raised, actually,
because we just got to
pretend all day long.
I had to create all kinds
of worlds in my head.
And we sang a lot, so music
was really my first way
into this crazy world of show.
But then I discovered the
theater in high school.
Then I went on to college
and studied acting,
and I've been at it ever since.
SPEAKER: Cool, Dolly.
You're next, yes.
NORBERT LEO BUTZ: Dolly, by
the way, is my mom's name.
And now I'm working
with Dolly Wells.
DOLLY WELLS: I'm called Dorothy.
NORBERT LEO BUTZ: Yes, and
you don't look anything
like my mom.
DOLLY WELLS: Do I not?
NORBERT LEO BUTZ: No, no.
DOLLY WELLS: OK.
NORBERT LEO BUTZ: You're
sweet like my mom.
I just didn't want to say
that when Dolly and I have
to kiss in the play
a lot, so I don't
think of my mom-- never
mind, this is getting weird.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: Keep going,
this is interesting.
DOLLY WELLS: Here we go.
NORBERT LEO BUTZ: You
take the mic away from me.
SPEAKER: Yes.
Doll, your father, John
Wells, correct, yes?
DOLLY WELLS: Yes.
SPEAKER: Very, very
successful in his own right.
DOLLY WELLS: He would
love you saying that.
He's not alive anymore,
but he was very wonderful.
He wasn't very, very,
very successful,
but he was a satirist
and a comedian.
He started up a magazine
called "Private Eye"
that lampoons most people.
And he was an actor.
He translated operas,
and he was a journalist.
He did millions
of things, and he
thought, towards
the end of his life,
that he did them very badly.
He thought he should
have just done one thing.
He started off as
a teacher Eton.
He taught French and German.
And at night, he would
climb out the window
and go to The Establishment,
which was this trendy comedy
place that Peter Cook, this
comedian, would put nights on.
And my dad would do it with him.
And one night it was
in one of the red tops,
on the bad newspapers.
It said "Eton master peddles
smut on the London stage."
He got asked to come
and see the headmaster.
And they said,
you have to decide
whether you would like to be
a teacher or peddling smut.
And he decided to peddle smut.
[LAUGHTER]
For the end of his
life, he thought
he should have carried on,
stuck to being a teacher.
SPEAKER: And did that influence
you to choose a career--
DOLLY WELLS: Yes, because
when I was very young,
his thing that he did
that was most noticed
was he imitated Mrs. Thatcher's
husband, Denis Thatcher,
in the West End.
He wrote a play that he put on.
And It lasted for two years.
And every night, he
would make up whatever
was going on in the news.
And so I would go
and watch him do it.
And I can remember standing
on the stage at about eight
or nine, just thinking,
this would be really fun.
And then at night, all his
friends would come home.
And I was noticing
that yesterday.
I've got a son who's 12.
And we were doing FaceTiming
and doing dares in the theater.
And anything that he asked
Zosia to do or Hamish to do
or the crew to do,
they were doing.
And I was thinking,
there's no way-- help.
There is no way he's not
going to be an actor now,
because actors are just
so nice to children.
ZOISA MAMET: We were
having so much fun.
They were great-- this
was like 15 minutes
before we went
onstage, by the way.
DOLLY WELLS: So yes, he did
influence me, definitely.
SPEAKER: And then Hamish,
your mother, who's
here in the audience, yes?
HAMISH LINKLATER:
My mom in the house.
There she is.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Who is your mother?
Tell us about her.
HAMISH LINKLATER: My mom's a
lady named Kristin Linklater.
She has a technique called
the Linklater technique, which
is taught in universities
across this country,
to help actors fill a space,
and also be great artists.
And so that's what
smut she peddle.
And when my mommy had me--
I'm going to tell
a long story now.
When my mommy had me,
just because she's here,
she had a good
university job at NYU.
She was in a good
financial place
to raise a child by
herself in New York.
When I got to be about two,
she was like, all right,
that's enough of that.
And she went off to start
this theater company called
Shakespeare and Company
in the Berkshires,
where this play is set.
And we moved into
an actor commune,
moved into this abandoned
mansion that was haunted.
It had maybe electricity,
but certainly not hot water.
It was built by Edith Wharton.
And so her ghosts, there
were real, real ghosts.
NORBERT LEO BUTZ: Yes!
HAMISH LINKLATER:
And you would hear
the footsteps of the maids
on the top floor at night,
and then sometimes a scream
and something like that.
ZOISA MAMET: Hamish,
where is this play?
HAMISH LINKLATER:
This is this play.
And I'm finally casting
myself in a role.
There was no money.
There were just ghosts.
But the idea was, we're going
to make a great American
Shakespeare troupe.
That's what I grew up with,
was sitting out on the lawn
and watching the Shakespeare
happening all summer.
And like you were saying,
actors are the best people
in the world.
Not a lot of people know that.
But when you're a kid,
they want an audience.
They're desperate for an
audience, those actors.
And little children love to
see people dancing around doing
things in pumpkin pants.
My mom made me--
[LAUGHING]
My mom made me a home,
and it was in the theater.
So I'm really grateful to her.
[CRYING]
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Is that the first
tear shed in a Google talk?
I think it might be, actually.
That was really-- thank you.
Thank you for that.
And thank you for--
KRISTIN LINKLATER:
We do cry a lot.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: The two of
you sit around and cry?
Everyone needs a
good cry session.
Just go see this show.
It's wonderful.
HAMISH LINKLATER:
Actually, that was
the one comment I got from
an audience member after it.
He was like, hey, did
you write the show?
It was at the end of the thing.
"Hey, did you write the show?"
I was like, yeah
I wrote the show.
He was like, "Are you crying?"
I was like, yeah, I'm crying.
"You're crying at
your own play?"
I said to him, "Why the fuck
do you think I wrote it?"
I like a cry.
And it's so great when we
have like two show days,
I get two cries in.
It's fabulous.
SPEAKER: So you still
go see the show.
Are you going to see
every show, do you think?
HAMISH LINKLATER: I go as
often as I possibly can.
Also, the audience teaches
you so much about the play.
So it's wonderful to get a
good variety of focus groups.
SPEAKER: It's very heavy
for the characters.
All the characters are
deeply, deeply flawed,
which makes them
all work together.
So I guess, for again
the cast members,
do you guys do anything
specific for this
to help you prepare for
the emotional journey
you have to go on?
ZOISA MAMET: We bounce
on the trampoline.
DOLLY WELLS: Twice.
Everyone has to do two bounces.
That was the extent--
the play, we don't--
I find that really hard talking
about that sort of thing
beforehand, because I find
that this sounds too English,
but it's cringe-y.
That's just what I find.
So I wouldn't probably say.
But I think that the play,
once you get onstage and start
speaking Hamish's words in
this play, that's got as many--
beautiful for us to be in and
do and know what we're doing.
I think you just have
to get on with it.
I don't know--
NORBERT LEO BUTZ:
That's exactly right.
I don't want to
keep pointing out
Ms. Kristin, the brilliant
Kristin Linklater over there,
but the first textbook--
most actors that go
through training programs
in this country have
to do Linklater work.
It was the first textbook that I
bought in my undergrad program.
I did the technique all
through undergrad school.
And so to be here now, with
her as an audience member,
and her son as a playwright
is just huge for me.
So how do I prepare?
I think back when I was 19
years old, and I read her work
and "How to Free the Natural
Voice" and all these types
of things, I think I was
preparing 35 years ago for what
I have to do.
But Dolly is exactly right.
There's really no-- you show up.
You make sure you have your
sleep, have your protein,
make sure you're rested,
warm up, and then get out
of your head.
There's no way to start
the play, or through it,
except through it.
And actors try to find so
many ways of how not to begin.
None of us want to start.
It's the worst.
Starting is the worst.
And this is true, I'm sure from
Olivier down to an overacting
ham like me.
You want to find
something-- oh please, don't
let it have to happen again.
Is there any way that I
can get to the curtain call
without actually having
to do all these things?
And there's not.
There's not.
I absolutely love
that about acting.
Every day it's a microcosm
of living your life, right?
One foot in front of the other.
Get out there, the play starts,
open up and move through it.
There's really no
way to prepare.
DOLLY WELLS: And also,
it's having more experience
with television, it feels
like quite a good lesson,
just for me, in how to try and
live life when you're onstage,
which is just basically,
listen very carefully
to what the other people
are saying to you,
and only listen to them.
And don't jump at all ahead,
even like a second ahead,
because you give
yourself a heart attack.
Because you're thinking, oh
my god, I don't know where--
I don't know anything.
So you just have to stay
very, very much in the moment
and listen and think, and feel.
ZOISA MAMET: Yeah.
DOLLY WELLS: You have to feel,
because it's done for you.
ZOISA MAMET: I mean, I
think feeling is good.
But he's written it very well,
so it's like half of it's
done for you.
But I also think,
hearkening back
to what Hamish said before,
that he wants us all
to have a good time, I think
he really accomplished that.
And the writing is--
we as actors, we are hams.
That's why we do what we do.
And we want to go on stage,
and we want to make you laugh.
We want to make you cry.
We want to make
ourselves cry for you.
We want to feel
all the feelings.
But I think, at
the end of the day,
and Hamish has said
this to us so often
throughout the
process, just have fun.
And I try and remember
that every time I go out
on stage every night, just that
I do this because I fucking
love it.
And it's this deep,
deep love of the game.
Because it is quite miserable
at times, and terrifying,
and sort of awful.
But it's like a compulsion.
We do it because we
have to, otherwise
we would have all been bankers.
And so, to remember that,
to be incredibly present,
and listen to the people that
you're onstage with, and then
also just, even in the
scenes where you're
weeping and crumpled
in a ball on the floor,
which I do too
much in this play,
just to remember
that you love it
and try and take a
huge bite out of that.
SPEAKER: Lovely.
There's a quote, actually
that I've found of Norbert--
do you want to add to that?
SCOTT ELLIOTT: I was just
going to say one quick thing,
that I see our job as
making you feel something.
That's what we do.
The only way we can do that--
I have the greatest
admiration and respect
for actors who are
able to do that.
That's the only way that
I could put my own job,
and make myself feel like
I'm doing something worthy,
is to think that our job is
to make people feel something.
SPEAKER: The quote I was
going to bring up here,
"It's thrilling to be on
stage, and to not know,
literally, what
the next moment is
going to bring, to just submit
to the not-knowingness of it.
I love that you said that.
Yes, question over here?
AUDIENCE: Thanks
so much for coming.
Can't wait to see it.
And on the topic of
liking to feel things,
I really appreciated how you all
talked about both the sadness
but also the humor in the play.
And I was curious if there
were any rehearsals that
were particularly humorous
that you could tell us
about that would give us
insight into the process?
ZOISA MAMET: I think they've
all been humorous at times,
especially with a play that
the subject matter is so heavy,
for lack of a better word.
You have to find the
humor in the process,
otherwise we'd all just
never show up for work.
So yeah, we laugh a lot.
DOLLY WELLS: Yeah, loads.
And also there's lines, that
however many times you hear--
Norbert and I always laugh
about when someone says,
there's a photograph on the
bar, and they say, "Who's that?"
one of the characters
just says "Ugly children."
[LAUGHTER]
Because we're all so
smug, thinking that
our children are so
beautiful, that we can laugh.
It's great.
Ha ha, imagine having
ugly children, ha ha.
Also, this sounds really
annoying and actor-y,
if we have sounded
like that already,
is that Scott and Hamish have
put together a group of people
that really, really
like each other,
and really find each other very
funny, which is really lucky.
Because you have moments like--
I have a moment when I
have to lie on a bed.
And I'm listening to
two or three scenes.
And you're listing to them
again and again and again.
But you're feeling so
lucky that you're not only
listening to really
powerful and interesting
and moving and funny
and peculiar words,
but you're also
listening to them
being done by really
talented people who you like.
So there's quite a few things
all happening at the same time,
that you feel quite pleased
about, because we all
get on very well, and
because everybody--
I can't think of anyone
that doesn't make me laugh.
We do all laugh quite a lot.
SCOTT ELLIOTT: It's awful
working with people who
don't have a sense of humor.
I mean, we've all
been in a situation
where we've worked with people
without a sense of humor.
And that's always hard.
But I always look
for people, actors--
I'm always attracted to
people with senses of humor.
It's my-- love it.
NORBERT LEO BUTZ:
I thought we were
going to get in trouble
the other night.
We were in our tech rehearsal.
We were on, like, hour nine
of just going cue to cue.
It's just drudgery.
It's just awful.
And it was like our eighth
day in a row or something.
And the play has a lot of joy,
there's a lot of sadness in it.
And we just get into
these giggle fits.
And I think your defenses are
down, your body gets tired,
and it's always--
Hamish, you know, you're
doing Shakespearean tragedies.
The end of those
plays, it's so hard
to do them with a straight face.
You're either all
in, you're all in.
SCOTT ELLIOTT: Yeah,
I remember that.
That was funny.
No, you guys were having fun.
I love watching
moments like that.
DOLLY WELLS: I've got an answer.
Sorry, go on.
SCOTT ELLIOTT: I
love when people--
I love it.
ZOISA MAMET: Are you talking
about when I said, [INAUDIBLE].
SCOTT ELLIOTT: I don't think
Hamish liked it very much.
But I really loved it.
DOLLY WELLS: Or when Norbert--
that's an answer that
I hadn't remembered--
and I must be very
gullible, but Grace,
the girl who lies
in the bed, he was
doing what he said with
his best English accent
for me and Grace.
And I was so amazed.
ZOISA MAMET: He said
it was for an audition.
NORBERT LEO BUTZ: I said, Dolly,
I have to go on an audition.
I have to do a British accent.
I think I've nearly got it.
Would you just have a listen
to me for a few lines?
And so I started to--
(IMITATING TERRIBLE BRITISH
ACCENT) [INAUDIBLE] like this.
I think I've just aboot got it.
To be or to be.
No, that one's not
right-- to be or to be?
And I had her going.
It was a dumbest
joke in the world.
Everybody else knew it
was the dumbest joke.
And she's like, oh, oh
god, he's really terrible.
But she was buying.
DOLLY WELLS: And I
was being so nice.
I kept saying, have you got
anything that I could help?
Just maybe, where's he from?
[LAUGHTER]
And me and Grace were just
pushing each other's leg.
I was really scared for him.
NORBERT LEO BUTZ: I said, well,
it's an interesting character.
He was born in London, but when
he was two, he moved to Utah.
But when he was 3 and 1/2
he moved back to London.
DOLLY WELLS: And then
he moved to Birmingham.
NORBERT LEO BUTZ: And then
he moved to Birmingham
when he was six.
So I'm trying to get
all these little sounds.
And she's nodding, going oh, OK.
Let me see if I
can get my head--
I was like, are you serious?
You're buying that shit?
DOLLY WELLS: I was
so disappointed.
ZOISA MAMET: Dolly Wells is
the most gullible human being
who's ever existed.
Every night, Noah
[? Bean ?] and I go--
Noah will be like,
"Hey Zosia, did you
hear who's in the audience?"
And Dolly will be like
"I know, you're joking,
you're joking-- who?
No, I know you're
joking, but who is it?"
SPEAKER: Judith Light.
Well, thank you guys
so much for coming in.
"The Whirligig" is
now at the beginning
of a limited run, which opened
May 4 going through June 11
And everybody please help me
give them a round of applause.